There are some very strong reasons why partners breaking up generally
try to remain friends. To the person being
– however nicely – rejected, the promise
of friendship can feel like an emotionally-reassuring
consolation prize. We may no longer be able
to share their bed, have children with them
or end our days in their company, but at least
something can be rescued from the ashes: we
will continue to be able to call them when
we like, share our fears and go to the movies
together. To the person performing – however
nicely – the execution, the promise of friendship
is equally attractive. We may be itching to
eject the partner but we are not – for that
matter – devoid of feeling. We are, as we
might say in sentimental moments, extremely
fond of the soon-to-be ex. We just don’t
want to end our time on earth with them, let
alone reject all sexual possibilities in their
name. Furthermore, we are deeply attached
to the idea that we’re not monsters. And
as we know, nice people always try to be friends
with their exes. The arguments may sound wise
but, from close up, they are deeply fraught
and in their own way, a catastrophe for both
sides. For the rejected party, the step from
lover to friend is an eternally humiliating
demotion. To go from the idea of a joint life-long
future to a dinner every second Thursday is,
to put it mildly, a come down. Worse, every
sighting of the ex is guaranteed to re-ignite
hope and then further insult. One isn’t
acquiring a friend, more an unwitting torturer.
As for the executing party, the ex is a constant
reminder of one’s guilt and ruthlessness.
One can’t even relax into being kind, lest
one’s intentions be misread and, after a
few drinks, they burst into tears or attempt to make a move.
The idea of trying to be friends constitutes a touching attempt
to honour the best sides of a relationship
in which two people invested heavily.
Lovers can’t, simplyvanish from each other’s lives after all
that; a friendship is invoked to memorialise
an episode of genuine importance. But, looked
at more dispassionately, friendship isn’t
in any real sense faithful to love. Friendship
with an ex does a grave disservice both to
the memory of the relationship at its height
and the merits of intimate friendship. It’s
at once a betrayal of everything a good relationship
was and a slight on the ideals of friendship,
which shouldn’t be built out of the remnants
of another, more ardent condition. What we
should replace love with isn’t friendship
but that far more honest state: civil distance.
That and a real assurance that the relationship,
in its best and most enduring light, will
always live on in the one place it can safely
always do so: memory.